si en este mundo hay una solución para
terminar con el hambre mundial es la
única solución podrá venir de la
compasión de un hombre hacia su prójimo
esta frase esa frase no le dijo ningún
filósofo la dijo superman
qué tal mi nombre es isaac rodríguez
flores pero soy mejor conocido como el
chico de los botes
el niño que vendiendo chicharrones con
salsa ayudaba a gente en situación de
calle
mi historia en el emprendimiento social
empieza a la edad de 12 años cuando un
día que me fui de pinta me topé con una
escena que me cambió la vida para
siempre
y ese momento fue ver a un niño de mi
edad trabajando en un semáforo
en ese momento me detuve a pensar
en todas las oportunidades que yo tenía
en todas las chances que yo sí tenía
y el no
es una sensación / molestia
disgusto coraje
no sé escribirla
solo sé que aquí adentro se movió algo
y estoy muy seguro que tú también has
sentido esa sensación cuando te has
topado con una escena
que te genera esas emociones
me encantaría decirles que el cambio en
mí fue inmediato y que al día siguiente
estaba haciendo grandes proyectos con
grandes ideas pero la verdad es que no
yo pasé por un proceso al cual yo titulé
en la activista de sillón
una activista de sillones esta persona
que se la pasa escribiendo en facebook
en twitter y en cualquier red social lo
mal que está todo el mundo lo mal que
están todos lo mal que estás tú lo mal
que estoy yo y todo el mundo está mal
pero estas personas son incapaces de
levantar el trasero del sillón y salir a
hacer algo
y yo fui de esos
y yo sé que tú también lo has ido
es más fácil quejarse
es más fácil
es decir que todo lo están haciendo mal
a salir a hacer un cambio
la frase que a mí me cambió y que me
motivó a tomar acción fue una frase muy
sencilla pero con mucho significado y
esa frase dice si algo te molesta
cámbialo
si algo te molesta
cambian
y yo me detuve a pensar que por qué
demonios me estaba quejando yo por el
niño del semáforo
si yo no estaba haciendo nada por él
me quejé en facebook no iba a cambiar
nada
así que decidí hacer algo mi mejor idea
en ese momento fue vender dulces en la
escuela así que me pasé toda una semana
guardando diez pesitos diez pesitos para
un lunes llegan con una bolsa de paletas
y vendérsela mis compañeros
aquí vencí a un primer miedo el miedo de
hablar con alguien
el miedo de hablar en público
a mí me congelaba pero sabía que era
para hacer algo más y lo hice
al final al final del día
le llevé algo de comer este chico
y la sensación que sentí después de eso
no se las puedo explicar tampoco porque
es algo que únicamente puedes sentir
cuando lo vives
y tiempo después después llegó la
preparatoria
en la prepa yo descubrí unas botanas
sumamente baratas que se vendían muy
bien si las acompañadas de salsa
y mi promoción de 3 por 10 pesos se hizo
famosa
yo llegaba a todos los días a la escuela
con una bolsa de tot is a cuestas cual
santa claus cargando sus obsequios y la
volaba por una barda detrás de la prepa
para que no me la quitarán en la entrada
y todos los días vendía mis totis y al
finalizar el día en la escuela yo salía
y le entregaba comida a gente en
situación de calle
no había cosa que me encantará más que
hacer eso
hasta que llegó mi primer gran momento
un profesor del nombre mario alberto
garcía
y de un evento para que entregáramos
sillas de ruedas a gente en situación
vulnerable que no las podía pagar
y durante este evento contable es un
espectáculo con el ayuda de todos los
alumnos que estuvieran en las clases de
artes de danza música
a mí su idea me encantó y yo me
comprometí con él que todo lo que yo
vendiera en totis se donaría
y por primera vez decidí contarle a
todos en la escuela para que eran mis
mis dotes mis ventas
y yo francamente esperaba una respuesta
mínimamente positiva
la verdad es que
ser llamado loco estúpido e incluso
ladrón
fueron de las cosas menos feas que me
llegaron a decir
y no me lo dijeron
mis compañeros
me lo dijeron mis profesores esas
personas que se supone que estaban ahí
para guiarme a ser una mejor persona
y en ese momento yo tenía dos opciones
la primera era tirar la toalla
y la segunda era intentarlo
había un motivo más grande así que me
animé a hacerlo y ya no llegaba a la
escuela con una bolsa llegaba con dos
bolsas de totes a cuestas todos los días
y con siete litros de salsa en la
mochila
después de unos meses
llegó el día del evento y fue un
completo éxito
logramos donar 16 sillas de ruedas
de las cuales 5
salieron únicamente de la venta de tot
is
ese momento me demostró que la suma de
muchas pequeñas acciones pueden lograr
grandes cosas
en ese momento me di cuenta que lo que
yo estaba haciendo
podía hacerse más grande
lleve el alter ego del chico totis
durante toda la preparatoria y parte de
mi universidad
y con gusto les cuento que sin cosillas
se transformaron en 10
y también se transformaron en unos
auxiliares auditivos para que una niña
volviera a escuchar
y ya no solamente era comida eran
despensas completas
sí
con chicharrones y salsa
a mí me inspira demasiado compartibles
este mensaje
porque si de algo estoy seguro
si de algo estoy seguro es que el chico
de los totes también eres tú
también eres tú
porque eres esa persona que quiere hacer
algo que busca cambiar algo
pero no sabe por dónde empezar
sabes que quieres cambiar algo en este
mundo que no sabes por dónde iniciar eso
a ti te hace el chico de los toffees
hoy quiero pedirte algo muy especial
quiero pedirte que te dejes de quejar
quiero pedirte que dejes la queja a un
lado y levantes el trasero del sillón y
salgas a hacer algo
haz algo por eso que a ti te molesta haz
algo por eso que a ti incluso te quite
el sueño con tus ganas con tu talento y
con tu energía puedes
pero solo necesitas querer hacerlo
me gustaría terminar con las primeras
palabras que una persona que creyó en mí
me dedico
con la venta de los topes
una chica me pagó con un dólar
el cual si hubiera visto que estaba
pintado quizás no lo hubiera aceptado
porque pintado ya no vale
pero tenía un mensaje
y este mensaje era que ella sí creía que
se le podía cambiar la vida a las
personas
unos totis a la vez
unos toques a la vez
muchas gracias
[Música]